so for instance now we went from other
than geometric features to our equation
right so you don't have to write this
down we'll go through some properties
emulator if I said to you x squared
equals say okay just suppose that's what
I gave you that's what I handed you
right now because we went from here and
ended up here you can see that this is
in this form do you agree that in the
same form right really that's x squared
equals how would you rewrite this in
this one with hands four times a 1 right
which you would normally say why did you
bother doing that like 32 ways simpler
right well the reason why we would
bother is because now I know what a is
right there is right there okay so
immediately I can now say all right now
that I have the equation I know where
the focus is and I also know what the
directrix is going to be if I work
backwards right the focus should be
exactly the focal length away from the
vertex do you agree with that okay so
where would that be if the focal length
is 8 yeah it's going to be 0 8 that's
that's how high it's going to be and in
exactly the same way I could say well
the directions has to be the young way
it's still 8 units away but it's below
so it's gonna be one of those eight see
that what if now going that example
swing that for what if I gave you this
good okay so I am still going to
preserve a as being eight okay but I'm
still angry that's gonna mean I rewrite
this like so x squared equals negative
four
hey why okay now what does this mean
though I still the same length that I
have here but it's upside down upside
down right so the focus will no longer
be above the parabola the focus should
be below okay because the whole thing is
upside down so I would say the focus is
on zero negative eight okay and
therefore the directrix will be above at
y equals eight
let me do one more let me do one more
and then I'll label some more stuff on
this parabola I hope it's big enough for
you if I flip these around okay let's go
WAIS where 32x mmm okay now we've seen
these before actually we've drawn these
right sure man but first it's in this
kind of form it's just the X's and Y's
are backwards right so let's just
quickly factorize it it's a four okay so
the focal length is still eight right so
it's gonna be the same I suppose you
could say the same steepness or fatness
as both of these guys right but how is
it different
okay so just quickly right this guy is
facing up so there's the focus and
there's the directrix right have a look
at this next one
this guy is facing down so the directrix
is up above and the focus is below so
now which way is this probably going
it's going off to the right isn't it sir
you can already see where the directrix
in the focus should be where would you
expect them to be here is the focus on
the right okay so that would mean
because the focal length is 8 what do
the corners do that look like
eight-zero right focus with me at eight
zero which implies the directrix is on
the other side and that's clearly
negative isn't it but be careful it's
not a horizontal line like these guys
the directrix will be vertical
negative eight and I don't need to do
another game but you can see it just
turns which way okay does that make
sense
all right so we introduced the focus
then we had the directrix I label that
again directrix if I can spell okay
introduce the focal length once you know
the correct form directly yeah okay
there's all my line I want to put on
here so you can go back to your labeled
thing see I've got the focal length
right there it's vertical okay there's a
line that goes straight across through
the focus the picker is a very important
point as you can see straight across
here
that is parallel to the directrix okay
it goes through the focus through the
focus and it's parallel to the directrix
this guy has a very strange or quit name
it's cool it has all it has a Latin name
okay it's cold the latus rectum now
before you think wait a second
that's like okay where does this come
from it came a custom not the same word
you're thinking you know it comes from
the same word that this comes from right
which means straight which is also when
you say okay there's like a picture on
the wall and it's like one key right
well the thing you should do with it is
you should rectify it
which means you should straighten it
well no they both come from the same
images to straighten something okay by
the way what you're thinking of when you
see this word does have the same root
it's not that this comes from that it's
that both of these things come from the
same thing which means straight okay and
you can you can go into a couple unit if
you really want to know why it means
straight but that's what it means it is
straight straight and I don't know if
this means if someone says to you like
gives your problem and says oh this
requires some lateral thinking well we
talked about you know on a planet right
on the planet you've got these lines
that go up and down and they're called
lines of longitude and then you have
these ones right then I call what they
call you they're called lines of
latitude because they go across they go
across you have to think across ways
outside of your normal way of thinking
right so it is going straight across
that's all it means
okay and it's through the focus